[Music]
we get 9
[Music]
that's Toussaint rain from Bruce
Springsteen's latest album is called
western stars now this album is headed
to the big screen I can't wait for you
to see it the concert film was recorded
at Springsteen's estate that's in New
Jersey of course that's where we talked
to the music icon and icon is the word
about starring in a Western of his own
the movie
Bruce Springsteen transformed this more
than 100 year old barn into a concert
hall complete with 30 piece Orchestra
for his new film western stars
it's part documentary it's part concert
it's part love story to me how do you
describe it doesn't quite have a genre
because it's a mixture of a performance
film
but there's all these sort of meditative
interstitial pieces where we made these
little films in between each song that
hopefully gives you a sense of deeper
meaning of what they're about here
we find those moments between the music
is where the singer/songwriter
reveals more of himself intro to Tucson
train
I spent my 10,000 hours and then some
learning my musical craft but I spent a
lot more time than that some 35 years
trying to learn how to let go of the
destructive parts of my character I
think after all the years of reflection
and struggle that you have and you still
find it a struggle it never stops I mean
ever no of course not that's life you
know life it's that way till you go into
the box I don't think it's supposed to
stop you know I know but Bruce I want to
get to the point where I don't want
struggle anymore I just don't turn stars
features Bruce Springsteen's first
collection of new music since 2012
it is also a nod to the Hollywood
Western with him in the title role you
write about the character you describe
him as a fading film stars yeah now are
you talking in some way about yourself
do you feel that about yourself as a
character I think every time you you
draw on a character you you draw on some
part of yourself you're using a lot of
detail that has nothing to do with you
or your life yeah but you are mining a
variety of different emotional veins to
make that's what people perceive as
authenticity today it's not necessarily
that the details of your song it's the
authenticity of the emotional life of
the song that you
so I always try to make that ring true
[Applause]
[Music]
it's also Bruce Springsteen like we've
never heard before it's like it's
country but yeah it's still you is that
what you wanted to you're always trying
to do that are you always trying to do
something different yeah what you've
tried to do is the audience wants you to
do two things they want you to surprise
them and make them feel at home
simultaneously and the better you can do
but those things at the same time the
further on down the road you get to go
on your journey with with your
[Music]
he also calls western stars a love
letter to Patti Scialfa
they got married in 1991 and have three
children we've been together for many
years but yet there is clearly a
intimacy between the two of you and it's
not that go get a room you two intimacy
it's just a very very special intimacy
that you still you've been together for
many years but yet there's still the
heat is definitely still there between
the two of you and we all like to see
that
[Music]
we're gonna gather for 30 years it's a
long you've shared a lot and Patty's
been to at the center of my life for the
entire half of my life you know and
provided normal enormous amount of
guidance and inspiration and you know I
can't overstate it you know it's it's a
I've been lucky so you said here's
another quote from the movie about love
we're always trying to find somebody
who's broken pieces fit with our broken
pieces and something hold emerges that's
beautifully second pieces are you
working with - you know I think you
can't have deep experience without error
mistakes pain that's all just a part of
human existence so what does art - and
music music is it's it's a repair shop
so I'm basically a repairman I'm trying
to repair myself if I do that well
enough I will help prepare you in the it
[Music]
[Applause]
Bruce Springsteen has been doing it for
audiences around the globe for close to
five decades now I've been to a few
Bruce Springsteen concerts I've never
seen you play less than three hours plus
okay I've never seen it and I think
people marvel that you can play as long
as you can and still seem to enjoy it
the way you yes I can
to deliver your best on any given night
some nights it's better than others but
there's never a night when it's not all
we have I take a seat at the bar it's
the kind of work ethic you'd expect from
the man known as the boss
why don't they even call you the boss
why the van started because I paid their
paychecks and that's how it started and
they would say go see the boss that
simple had nothing to do with anything
grander grander than that so it but it's
it's it's followed me mine I kind of
like it though I kind of like it you
know I do like it I don't get the
impression he like birds I think he's
very comfortable with that but this is
the thing I can't stress enough about
this this this album and this movie in
particular you've got to see it on the
big screen my recommendation is first
listen to the music before you go the
music has been out now about a month and
then go see the see it on the big screen
the strings Anthony and Tony and the way
that it shot and it so beautifully done
and to hear Bruce speaking so personally
about his life yes yes music and his
love if you didn't get to see his
Broadway show when he did that - this is
it's it's it's really moving on this
gives you goosebumps I promise you you
will not be disappointed opens tomorrow
by the way I love what he says about
music he says it's essentially a repair
shop I repair myself when I do it well
I'll repair again - I love that record
it's like it I think it was a curveball
for a lot of people but it's really good
it's really good
you can watch western stars in theaters
nationwide this weekend did I tell you
have to see it on a big screen and our
conversation with Bruce Springsteen
continues tomorrow he talks about his
parents and foods as well as the dad
he's got three kids response to recent
criticism from President Trump